times are tough jobs are scarce it's
risky to be outside and around
others seems like there's very few ways
to make extra money
during a pandemic so i guess i'll just
hunker down
and binge social media until this all
blows over
wait don't these people make money
how do these people make money
[Music]
streamers youtubers twitch stars how do
they make money
is it a lot is it a lot of work i know i
gotta ask somebody in the biz
and i got just the guy austin john plays
this is your full-time job now right as
of november of last year yes
this was always just kind of like a side
thing like
any money that i made from doing my
videos and whatever else i never touched
that
because i didn't really think of that as
being like real money and then
it started coming in more and more and
then it was like i hit my first day that
i broke a grand and i was like
this is actually gonna be money how did
the youtube channel
come to be when the game pokemon
sun and moon came out for the 3ds there
was like
things that i learned about the game and
then i i wanted to just share that
information with people
and at the time i didn't have any way to
capture a screen or anything so
i found like generic footage and i kind
of put it all together with
so much editing and that video got
six views and then two days later i made
another one
and that one got 12 views and then i
just started pumping out more and more
content and people were like
this guy knows what he's talking about
it really just started building on top
of itself and then it was like
my channel really focuses on tips and
tricks so i'd play
a straight 18 hours and i'll finish the
game or get to about the 40 hour mark
and then i'll make my first video while
i'm going through i have
a giant notepad and just scribbles
everywhere and i make these notes of
like the things that stumped me
so i know the things that may stump
other people
uh what do you need to think about if
you're building your youtube channel
one you need to do something that you're
passionate about
not that you like not that you think
you're gonna make money on something
you're passionate about
the other thing is something that other
people are passionate about
it holds a special place to them and
third is
it needs to be something that people are
gonna seek out information on
there are hundreds of millions of
channels
on youtube and in order to
enter into the marketplace you either
need to
uh be better than everyone else
you either need to be faster than
everyone else or you need to be more
accessible
than everyone else and you can't be more
accessible because it's already on the
platform granted if you understand how
the algorithm works which is very
similar to google analytics then
yeah you can have a little bit of a head
start but if you're not doing it faster
if you're not doing it better than
everyone else then why should anyone
watch your channel
um so my income as a youtuber
kind of breaks down to three different
ways uh
one which is the bulk of it which is ad
revenue
whenever you go and you watch a video
and then there's an ad and you wait five
seconds and you hit the bottom right
corner
and then you go on to the next video or
a non-skippable ad or
the video starts a media you get the
little banner ads at the bottom or
uh if you scroll down from the video the
first thing that shows there is an
ad those are the four different types of
ads that can appear on every single
youtube video
and all of them pay a certain amount
it varies on lots of things like the
country
of the person who posts it the country
of the person who watches it
the time of year where you are in the
quarter if there's anything going on
with
a reduction in ad revenue like great
example coven 19
companies weren't just spending as much
on advertising so because of that
cpm went down uh
cpm stands for click per thousand i'm
using the roman numeral for a thousand
and that means that for every 1000 views
you get a certain amount of money
now on low ads when i first started off
my cpm was
30 cents so every thousand views i made
30 cents
but then once i signed with an mcn and i
started making more quality content and
more engaging content
some of my better videos and certain
times of the year i can see cpm's as
high as
12 to 14
and there's a big fluctuation between
you know if i post a video
when there's no ads being spent like
january and february
that's the reason a lot of your favorite
youtubers and also tv shows
don't post new videos uh in that time of
year
because ad rates are down why are they
going to make content then instead
you're recording and you're bulking up
for when ad revenue is higher
the second way that a youtuber makes uh
income
is support crowdfunding
things like that when i first started
off patreon was really the only
option but then they started rolling out
supporters and members for youtube
channels so
whenever i have a live stream you can
click a button and then you can become a
member and then you get
special uh icons next to your name i
believe they're called badges or on any
video you can hit the join button and
that helps support the channel
which also integrates with my discord
and we get to have private conversations
and everything else like that and
we value you as a member of the
community
and it goes to help support you know me
making my videos
and then the third aspect to that would
be merch
and for me my merch has been somewhat
basic in fact i'm wearing
one of my t-shirts from last year right
now
and uh some of it integrates below a
video
and some of it you have to leave
off-site and then of course if you
mention it during a video you're better
uh you get more engagement you have to
endure the times that your first video
gets six views that you posted on reddit
and they say shut up and then an auto
mod bans you
you have to go through that because
until you go through that
and you discover why you're doing it
you're not doing it for other people
you're doing it for yourself
if you're not loving what you do then
it's not worth it
[Music]
huh so make a channel about something
that i'm passionate about
oh sweet i guess i can make the channel
about that
now how do i grow an audience
how do i get popular
it's all about diversification right you
have to have a massive twitter following
you have to have a massive instagram
following you have to have a massive
youtube following
of course you have to be on twitch which
is the key platform but
basically any way you can get in front
of your audience you can engage with
your audience
um it is going to drive those clicks
which ultimately drives the advertiser
revenue that you get back from
all of these platforms it's me and dan
playing video games and talking in a
funny manner over them
they're not just people who are good at
games they're actually people who are
good
at online engagement online
entertainment first and foremost you
have the right to remain stylish
anything you wear can and will be used
against you in the court of fashion
the streamer is either very very
talented
at the game the best player in the game
is generally going to draw a crowd
because people like watching people who
are very good
on the other hand they're either very
very good or funny
charismatic whatever it is on that side
you know it becomes more of a show where
they talk about other things
outside of the gaming world and gaming
becomes really just a backdrop and an
excuse to engage with that audience
there were those weird like ronald
mcdonald like straight to vhs movies you
remember those
i'm personable i'm chatty i would kind
of you know when boring things were
happening in the game i would ramble on
about you know
movies i'd watched or books i'd read and
you know or conversations i'd had
and stuff like that and so i think being
personable was a big part of that
it's not just getting on and playing
games it's getting on and being an
entertainer
you are putting on a show all right now
let me go ahead and grab the samurai
sword that every gym has
okay he's dead to have a larger audience
and and to
have that audience i think stay with you
you have to bring something extra
you know you have to find your niche you
have to find what works and what
connects with the audience and what
makes them laugh and what makes them
keep coming back
then you got to make it a little more
exciting all right
throw in a hanging bishop have everybody
in suspense for a moment
[Music]
i think the real most important thing is
is to just get used to being on camera
like
in any sort of performance thing is get
used to talking on camera
um you know i was my first few videos
were terrible
but because i sat down and did it for
six to eight hours a day
i just got used to talking and i got
over that uncomfortable hump
if you go into twitch purely with the
expectation that you're going to
make money make a job out of it have all
this growth and it's going to be great
you're probably going to burn out prior
to getting to that point
because there's very little payoff for a
long time right like
multiple years generally before you
really start to see a payoff
and so you know those first few times
you're streaming
nobody is there one person shows up
every 30 minutes says hi
maybe and leaves right like it's very
uh discouraging i think for a lot of
people
and so you have to be there just loving
it you have to love talking to yourself
when nobody is around you have to love
just the game that you're playing all of
that stuff
because it takes a while and i think a
majority of people
burn out prior to getting to the like
profitable point of it
and there you have it my very own
youtube twitch discord and streaming
channels all ready to go live it's a
veritable
social media ecosystem just on the verge
of
thriving so don't forget to smash
like and subscribe and visit my patreon
for perks
also go to my merch page and one last
thing
stay cool my friends
you